Transcriber: şükriye karaca
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Balık kavağa çıkınca
deyimini bilir misiniz?
Bir şeyin ne kadar zor, ne kadar imkansız
olduğunu anlatmak için kullanılır.
Öyle ya, balık bu.
Ne ayakları var, ne kanatları var.
Uçsa uçamaz.
Koşsa koşamaz.
Tırmansa tırmanamaz.
Yapabildiği tek şey yüzmektir.
İnsanların büyük bir kısmı sudaki herhangi
bir balığın o koskoca kavakta
ne işi olacağını düşünür.
Çıkamayacağını düşünür.
Yapamayacağını düşünür.
Asla başaramayacağını düşünür.
Peki ya ben?
Ben o balığın o kavağa çıkabileceğine
inanırım.
Evet, balık kavağa çıkar.
Hem de öyle bir çıkar ki.
Yeter ki bunu istesin.
Şimdi size bir hikaye anlatacağım.
Kavağa çıkmayı başaran bir balığın
hikayesini, içinde yaşadığımız zamanın
ve bu toprakların çok ötesinde bir yere
götüreceğim sizi 1900′lü yılların başına.
Bilirsiniz, bir ortamda
arabalardan konu açıldığı zaman
gözler hemen erkeklere çevrilir.
Karşıdan son model bir araç geçtiğinde,
bir marka yeni bir model ürettiğinde
birine bir araba parçası gerektiğinde
laf erkeklerin arasında döner durur.
Otomotiv sektörü sadece erkeklerin
ilgi alanıymış gibi düşünülür.
Aynı ortamda ev işleriyle, temizlikle
mesela cam silmek ile alakalı bir konu
geçtiğinde ise gözler hemen
kadınlara çevrilir.
Bu tarz konular sadece kadınların
ilgi alanıymış gibi düşünülür.
Bundan yüz yirmi sene evvel Mary Anderson
isimli bir kadın bir gün New York’u
gezmeye gitti.
Dışarıda yoğun bir kar yağışı vardı.
Bir tramvaya bindi.
Tramvay sürücüsü az ilerde
tramvayı durdurdu.
Aşağı indi.
Ön camı temizledi.
Ardından tekrar koltuğuna oturarak
travmayı sürmeye devam etti.
Kar o kadar hızlı yağıyordu ki, tramvay
sürücüsü sık sık travmayı durdurmak ve
aşağı inmek zorunda kaldı.
Mary Anderson bir müddet tramvay
sürücüsünü izledi, izledi.
Onun sağa sola giden kol hareketleri bir
şeyler çağrıştırdı, ilham oldu da
diyebiliriz aslında.
Ve bu sayede camı temizleyecek daha pratik
bir yöntem üretmeye karar verdi.
Evet, bugün sıklıkla kullandığımız ve
hayatımızı ciddi ölçüde kolaylaştıran cam
sileceklerinin mucidi bir kadındır ve bu
kadın yani Mary Anderson, ürettiği bu
çubuk sayesinde bütün dünyaya
ben de varım diyebilmiştir.
İçindeki üretme tutkusunu destekleyerek
birçok insana ulaşabilmiştir.
Biliyor musunuz?
Asıl mesleği
sığır yetiştiriciliğidir aslında.
Fakat o ürettiği bu çubuk sayesinde kendi
çiftliğini sınırlarını aşmış,
çok uzaklara ulaşmıştır.
Peki bu hep böyle mi olur?
Yani bir insan tutkularının peşinden
gitmek için mutlaka sınırlarını zorlamak
zorunda mıdır?
Ya da şöyle sorayım her kadın
Mary kadar şanslı mıdır?
Elbette hayır.
Her kadın Mary kadar şanslı değildir.
Bazı balıklar da o kavağa çıkmadan,
sınırlarını aşmadan, kendi sularında
kalarak başarırlar bunu.
Mesela benim anneannem.
Yörük kadını Hayriye.
Söz hakkı tanınmadan, öyle isteyip
istemediği falan sorulmadan, babasının
zoruyla yapılmış bir evlilik düşünün.
Eşi kendisinden otuz yaş büyüktü.
Çarşıya gitmesi dahi yasaktı anneannemin.
Bu yüzden koskoca ömrünü
iki odalı bir evde geçirdi.
Biliyor musunuz?
Hiç sevgi görmedi benim anneannem.
Eli hiç tutulmadı mesela.
Saçı bir kere okşanmadı.
Bugün ne güzel olmuşsun, elbisen çok
yakışmış, ellerine sağlık hayatım, yemek
şahane olmuş, iyi ki varsın, seni çok
seviyorum cümlelerinin hiçbirini duymadı.
Yani, diğer balıklar kadar şanslı
değildi benim anneannem.
Okyanusu, denizi, gölleri,
nehirleri unutun.
O iki odalı ev var ya, orası benim
anneannemin daracık fanusuydu.
Buna rağmen bir kez olsun kendini
umutsuz hissetmedi.
Onun yerine bir başkası olsaydı belki
çoktan pes etmişti ama anneannem hayata
hiçbir zaman küsmedi.
Ne yaptı biliyor musunuz?
Farklı şartlara sahip olamayacağını
anlayınca sahip olduğu şartları
güzelleştirmeye çalıştı.
Yaşadığı bütün zorluklara rağmen hayata
tutunabilmenin bir yolunu buldu.
İçinde kalan bütün o ukdeleri, bütün
hayallerini ve bütün umutlarını bir
tutkuya bağladı.
O tutku anneannemin
çıkartamadığı sesi oldu.
O tutku onun küçücük dünyasındaki
büyük mücadelesi oldu.
O tutku üretmekti.
Söyleyemediği ne varsa her birini iğnenin
deliğinden geçirip önündeki kumaşa
batırdı anneannem.
İçinin yangınını,
içinin baharını,
içinin dört bir yanını kaneviçe
yaptı ve tek tek işledi.
Dedem ona bir kere bile çiçek
almamıştı mesela.
Belki de bu yüzden anneannem evde bulduğu
bütün boş kutuların içine
rengarenk çiçekler dikti.
Ben basit bir salatalığın bile hiçbir
şekilde ziyan olmadığını ondan öğrendim.
Anneannem soyduğu bir salatalığın içini
cacığa doğrar, kabuğunu ise önce yüzüne
yapıştırır, ardından artan yemeklerle
birlikte tavukların önüne koyardı.
Harika bir terziydi mesela.
Dikiş masasının başına oturup birbirinden
güzel elbiseler dikerdi.
Etekler dikerdi.
Pantolonlar, yelekler, gömlekler dikerdi.
Mahalledeki bekar kızların
hepsine gelinlik dikerdi.
Hani terzilik işlerinden minicik
kumaşlar artar ya.
İşte anneannem o minik kumaşları
hiçbir zaman değersiz görmezdi.
Çöpe atmazdı.
Onları yan yana getirip uç uca ekleyerek
kırk yama örtüler dikerdi.
Tıpkı anneannemin diktiği bu kırk yama
örtüde olduğu gibi,
bu hayatta hiçbir şeyin boşa gitmediğini
onun sayesinde defalarca şahit oldum.
Bir şeyin mutlaka başka bir şeye
dönüştüğüne defalarca şahit oldum.
Sonra kendime baktım, içimdeki üretme
aşkına baktım ve anneanneme
dair izler gördüm.
Ben anladım ki bir kuşaktan diğer kuşağa
sadece saç şekli, göz rengi boy uzunluğu
falan değil, hayata baktığımız pencereler
de aktarılıyor, tutkular da aktarılıyor,
umutlar da aktarılıyor.
Evet, tıpkı anneannem gibi sahip olduğum
şartları iyileştirmeyi çok seviyorum.
Bir şeyi başka bir şeye dönüştürmeyi
çok seviyorum.
Olduğum yerde öylece oturmak
yerine ayağa kalkmayı,
bazen küçük bazen de büyük şeyleri
üretmeyi çok seviyorum.
Hiçbir şey yapamasam mesela, o gün
sıktığım bir limonun kabuğunu
çöpe atmamayı deniyorum.
Onu ince ince doğrayıp kuruttuktan sonra
limon aroması elde ediyorum.
Mimarlık fakültesinde okurken derslerim
hayli ağır olmasına rağmen bir tasarım
ofisine girip çalışmaya başlamıştım.
Mekanlar tasarlamıştım.
Projeler üretmiştim.
Onca yoğunluğa rağmen bana bunu yaptıran
şey içimdeki üretme tutkusu olmuştu.
Ya da sosyal medya da sadece gittiğim
bir yeri ya da yediğim bir yemeği
paylaşmaktan öte, insanların hayatına
dokunabilecek belki birkaçının yarasına
merhem olabilecek yazılar yazma
çabam işte bu yüzden.
Anneliğimin en zor, en yoğun
zamanlarını hatırlıyorum.
Böyle zamanlarda ufacık boşluklar
bulabilirdim ancak.
Mesela ocağın başında çorba
karıştırmak gibi.
İşte böyle anlarda elimdeki telefonun
notlar bölümünü açıp kelime kelime yazdım
ben ilk kitabımı.
Ardından sağlık problemleriyle sınandığım
o zor zamanlarda içinde çokça umut
barındıran ikinci ve üçüncü
kitaplarımı yazdım.
Beni iyileştiren şey tutkum oldu.
Beni iyileştiren şey üretmek oldu.
Tabi öyle hiç yani hep koşmadım, bazen
hiçbir şey yapmadığım zamanlar da oldu.
Böyle zamanlarda tüm kalbimle inandım.
Bir insanın yaşadığı bütün aksaklıklara
rağmen hayatı bir ucundan sıkı sıkı
tutabileceğine inandım.
Kış kıyamet demeden kırıldığı o yerden
yeniden yeşerebileceğine inandım.
İnceliklerden zerre kadar anlamayan
insanlara denk gelsem dahi kendi bahçemi
yeşertmekten asla vazgeçmem
gerektiğine inandım.
Hayat bana metrelerce kumaş vermediğinde,
yani elimdeki kumaş
bir elbise bile etmediğinde
oturup halime üzülmek
yerine ayağa kalkmaya inandım.
Hayatın bana verdiği minik mutlulukları
tıpkı anneannemin kırkyama örtüsü gibi
yan yana ekledim.
Diktim ve çoğalttım.
Bu yüzden bu resimde görmüş olduğunuz
şey sadece bir örtü değil aslında.
Bu örtü var ya bu örtü benim
bu hayatı oldurma şeklim.
Ben inanıyorum ki bizler tutkularımızın
ardından gittiğimiz zaman karşımıza
çıkacak zorlukları daha güçlü
göğüsleyebiliriz.
Olumsuzluklar üst üste geldiğinde şöyle
bir bakarız etrafımıza birkaç küçük
mutluluk bulur, uç uca ekleriz.
Düştük mü?
Kalkarız.
Dağıldık mı?
Toparlanırız.
Önümüze bir engel mi çıktı?
Başka yol seçeriz.
Başarısız mı olduk?
Biz de yeniden deneriz.
Yeter ki şunu hiç unutmayalım.
Yarınlar sayısız yeniden başlama fırsatı
sunar ve hiçbir şey için
geç kalmış değiliz.
Eğer istersek çorak topraklarda
bile çiçekler açtırabiliriz.
Eğer istersek, eğer gerçekten istersek
biz o kavağa çıkabiliriz.
Teşekkürler.